it does appear that the Apple doesn't
really far fall far from the tree now
for the first time in presidential
history we have both the president and
his zero experienced son facing criminal
investigations no surprise there the
father-son duo they seem to do
everything together finances they're
co-mingle they take trips together they
shared Vehicles together credit cards
together Hunter even lived with pops
well into his 40s and it is an
undeniable fact that the pair did
business together now this of course all
despite Joe Biden's many denials and
breaking tonight we have even more
evidence from the laptop from hell of
Hunter look at this at a 2017 email now
Unearthed by The Daily Mail they discuss
a plan to Loop in Joe Biden on a deal
involving the selling of American
liquefied Natural Gas to China now the
message was addressed to Jim and Hunter
Biden it introduces a point of contact
for the deal and it reads quote I have
requested him to be available for a call
from Joe Biden and Hunter Biden on
Monday morning to discuss the purchase
of the 5 million tons of gas this is for
China they are our number one
geopolitical foe now around the same
time in 2017 the Biden family remember
they got that 5 million dollar
interest-free forgivable loan from the
Chinese energy Giant cefc and would
everyone in our studio audience quick
question would you all like a 5 million
dollar interest-free forgivable loan
now
I think the word forgivable do you all
agree that the word forgivable means
that means you don't have to ever pay it
back doesn't it that would be considered
oh I don't know where I grew up very bad
word anyway now keep in mind none of the
bidens have any actual experience in the
energy sector remember 100 went on GMA
every any experience in energy no oil no
gas no Ukraine no why are you getting
paid Millions he answered I don't know
maybe because of your dad probably now
Hunter's expertise was in well to be
honest crack cocaine and hookers not oil
and gas anyway Uncle Jimmy was was
Hunter's best friend and Joe was a
career politician gearing up for a
presidential run he flat out lied to all
of you in this audience all of you at
home about having never one time ever
spoken to a son Hunter about his foreign
business partners now this will likely
be Joe Biden in my opinion this will be
his undoing not the top secret
classified documents that we have now
found in four separate locations so
think about it why on Earth were the
bidens breaking in millions of dollars
in this case from China on a liquefied
natural gas deal our number one
geopolitical fault to me the answer is
obvious China they weren't buying gas
they were paying for Access so the
question tonight is Will Joe Biden ever
be held accountable in any way now also
think about this the Penn Biden Center
they got 67 million dollars in mostly
Anonymous donations from Chinese
Nationals oh
47.7 million of which came when Joe
Biden left the vice presidency and moved
into the Penn Biden Center I'm sure they
just really were interested in Joe's
writings because they're so brilliant
and so deep and profound
now we have over in Davos Switzerland at
the world economic Forum well you have
your FBI director now under
investigation by Jim Jordan and the
Judiciary Committee he seems more
interested in colluding with big Tech to
control your speech on social media pay
very close attention to what your FBI
director says especially in light of the
FBI weekly meeting with big Tech in the
lead-up to the 2020 election take a
listen and I think the sophistication of
the private sector is is improving and
and particularly important the level of
collaboration between the private sector
and the government especially the FBI
has I think made significant strides now
the operational on the FBI they love a
little collaboration now meanwhile the
entire Biden family was raking in cash
from all these sketchy foreign Nationals
in Russia Ukraine Kazakhstan China and
the FBI they didn't either notice or
they didn't care and now Christopher
Wray has been pretty hands off in terms
of garage gate well they raided
Mar-A-Lago why didn't Joe Biden's many
homes get raided why no search warrant
why weren't they involved in searching
for other documents that we now know
they found they did nothing they're just
letting the Biden's personal lawyers
including some aides that do not have
security clearances perform their own
search so let me poll the audience how
many of you think that Joe's classified
document Scandal will end his political
career
or do you think it's going to be more
about the money how many think it's
documents raise your hand
how many think that the money from China
Russia Ukraine Kazakhstan how many of
you think that that might be a bigger
deal for the Biden family
the Biden Syndicate any of you disagree
I was always a liberal in every crowd
you know hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else